My name is Brian have broke today's June ninth we're at the newest breach of the
Brooklyn public library. I'm joined by Barbara Hobson for our streets
our story.
So tell me a little bit so I made my
grandson do some of the sixteen that I can pull in Vicksburg Mississippi.
And if he had American history with Arizona the Kansas.
And they do five every Sunday in the toilet.
My
father my whole family. They were sharecroppers.
And when I was
going. He was one abuse year problem because he never had enough
money and you were new cars new clothes he
decided that he wanted to go
mobile. My parents broke up my grandmother in
that with me because they was eighteen years old they want to do what I was doing
that so we ended up and minute. Oh the poor I looked
at Minnesota I lived on duty in
the streets in Jackson
Mississippi. Maku of the Pullman porter migration was
in full going to Mississippi to California and going
from Mississippi to Chicago and going to the man that.
Martha said he didn't want to live in Chicago so he took us to many happy.
Magnus's full man in the avenue
not. At the beginning to grow. My father say he wanted me in
his mother near him. So this took us to Gary in
the best weather gear and then analyses for that
was what I was a school.
Flava or piece of silk mill and he decided that this film those
he wanted
to go to set up machine nationalists he didn't want to is he was born there.
He worked as a ship with the
foundry on a ship out. That means when you put seal on a paid
leave that ship demoted back to
loose and that means you can all burn up on that high
ad and if a man falls in the morning made in a car they mean
to give us a day off maybe supposed to Scott. Wasn't doing enough but they
just supposed to just
fly. By the time I was
seventeen I got married
and my husband what Chicago to get a job because the plants were going down and
what's going on not so much.
I was made to use and I had my daughter my husband went to service but
on and came home. My daughter came
up and then we stayed in Chicago. We broke up so I decided
to side grandfather had come here in one thousand nine hundred and my father's becoming periodic
in New York. We moved to New York. Moved and
underneath the street between minutes and seconds.
Later on I'm going back to school moved to the Bronx and then I went to school and I had high
school diploma which I didn't have before.
And I stopped working for
the city of New York. They were very short of nurses and they gave a
wide
test and the test said nobody could go to school it was same
time it was impossible. Because the work was a long study
hours. So Washington after we took the Ted came out on top
and they call us the cream of the
crop. So this inner man from Washington D.C..
And
we met the bill be
auditory that in time. That would give us a kick
up a divided Hackler some of us went to the Bronx which I was living
there some state in
Manhattan. After we graduated I was no television.
As an answer then news. I didn't get a chance to
see myself because by the time I came back into the newsroom all my mother came for the great.
Interation and I were for the Department of hospitals
of nineteen sixty three.
Until I retired thirty one he is tatted fifty four with that had been the
big question then to blame. They don't give me an extra money just leave if you want to
so I've had people with that I've had that in the. Oh and by the way
when you graduated
this is a man back from Washington D.C. to see us graduate because they
said
that it was a hardship and they send the money they have everybody was very happy that
we
graduated because i'm said manpower had been given
to people on welfare
and people know if they didn't want to do this it was to get it checked out I gave
the city the nationwide Ted.
When asked the came out of school. Bedside was born
to a beloved state they had a lot of
houses abandoned all the books and in fact houses or what about.
The neighbor he had paid two hundred fifty to his house in fact he still does over.
Happen though. I met his family and I told
him I said gee I'd like to get money so I went back and got my car.
About someone else and I walked the street and I found a house to sixty five
friends up for your house break.
Washington D.C. was asking for two thousand dollars for.
My
boys but now we offer two thousand
five hundred one of the cages and call back and say you got it.
So then they have a lot next door was going for fifty dollars at another and I
don't want to buy what I can choose
because they give you the house as it
is you have to fix
up. To the. I was to my left
house and some of the fifty
dogs may have
gone and I think the house next door might have been a hundred
or so leave the lavatory the property
was a fool of herself but nobody wanted to buy. That's why ought to have been the stock
of people who knew how to quit because most people
I guess were crazy did not
fix. Those houses
have gotten
rich all through that had put back into
place those one is a so large
and Samantha stand in the winter and have room in the casket to come
through they would still
be got to put Windows
when we got to group
immunity Gaskin put on new premises by the side of the computers and. The whole house was a few
minutes.
Then I decided to come over here to live in New York.
I had wanted a new home out of used to being in the West where you had to live.
And kitchen and I used to kitchen it. Our lives we didn't have kids and
then we have my house you have a backyard sweat you up and when I came to New York. I
was shocked to see people on a dog in the
street because we do that they do you have a dog a way to
go and check it out and I told my friends about it we came of them want to have
to work and
I was supposed to be
exact and they had one we like and fallen out of the hole. To another house
in moved to a one one house had two bedrooms another
room other the house at three. So I've been as I have
come in from out of town. I wanted that we needed give me this what I took some of the seven thousand in there
because of the spiritual.
And the I had you had to pay one hundred dollars down. That's a picture name on the list.
So I paid one hundred dollars. And when I was doing is five
years abandoning each year for the news now and.
So I ask nothing can snap out of this and that's gone on T.V. I don't know what it
was so I decide to call it what number are you up to and after
that number is pretty close to man.
And sure enough when I was going to Calif one of the ridges they usually
use misuses now as when I'm going to California as in I can't get the papers together.
Herman put my name. When I come back I'm giving the place in the TO
THE So Sheridan. I took all the documents in.
And they called me for the fifth of October.
And I moved into my brand new house. Since about
two and I was so
happy she you imagine her brand new
cars placard that I had bought property of the Channel
eleven out of the land Sid out to Maison
landed it is a suburb of mine which is a beautiful city
that
subject and I had saved my money and apertures I still went down there I ate the lamb with
it that was supposed to my wood time
now. But it.
The kind of wood down. People didn't have jobs so I
decided that I would retire from New York
City and I Gap's what blast so Mt with jack crap about
because you want to give up a house. Eighty's or the land and the hell
and the whole
con My name is on seventeen of the sun has twenty four and
that neighborhood than a school
it's so I think there's a difference I've retired from the
private hospitals. I'm going to New York I'm not going to believe this is because
less than.
OK. That's so interesting how would
you
describe
this year to you your daughter grew up in
your mind. It was born in Chicago and came here when
she was too.
She stayed in New York till she was thirteen and that's when I bought my
house and could have you know that Kommersant is used to having the marketing
been agreed
upon what it was a commercial you know but that
Kommersant was some
hope with high school in New Jersey. That's where she went to school and
then when she came out of who she wanted a burger.
She went to Little Falls New Jersey going to come to visit business because when
it comes to the of the trainee they have to practice because you know. So people who
don't know the city of them know very bitter because the of the
Berkeley downtown in Manhattan but she can show the new falls Missouri and she
began executive
secretary. And good as
the bank moved out to
New Jersey all
quarters all those need to know and that money money
money all the socketed so she went to school that day she
came down Wall Street to work and when you know I would have to have lunch
with she is almost seventy four so me don't even
go you don't even see that in the
back and when those girls get a job they tell them how to pick
the window when to keep to will you to the job and they have a code that
these and that the lady doesn't take the job the agency called them
back and ask them how many windows. Did you take the job because if you don't think the
job is in you some places they don't have to look for jobs. Very good job to the
other and no that's why those who's going
to be chosen to have my daughter met
her on Wall Street. He's up.
He is the one who read the paper work for banks when the
merge How would you cough but that's what he does is an acquisition. How
will he put the paperwork for the bank when he gets to merge with another and he.
Connected to college so they are behind Rector's. And her neighbors
are professors that represent versus They live
in
Scouting New Jersey and their grandson has raised others. In
fact he graduated it about in their careers were babies coming out of a new
city and they were raised. Let's with some babies up
because they were brought there when they were three months so and
then after they began to
walk and look around. Everybody comes the baby to their base to walk to the principal's
office and keep the principal with them to have and then they will beg picture to be walking
around so they graduated with the Seton Hall he wouldn't finish
on the line with him but the sent him to
see Hollywood go. So all those kids' college
educated is no bums who
are those people have money in the well S.S. They don't even have the outfit
we don't have a come
out after having come back in a year know how to get back and
then you come back to a certain way and they have people who
have both parts I have a house and a diesel back they have water called back
in it or just on what you said to him.
So they have a lot of changes over there but
little question. They are not the middle of the meal
people and he can meet every day from lasted to New York City downtown in the forty's.
So I always told him. Do
it because you came in don't get with a whole meal here. We did a marathon in those we
did after the but is over
the N.G.'s because it was all need come abroad to New York City to the next
the know how much.
They are needing one too. They know how much it was. Because
you got the Peterson family.
So in a way I got that mirror of them whether they have or they may need is back to.
To hurry. She's now my daughter's fiftieth were she to decide to act on the six.
And I have a daughter that was
from Africa. I went to Ghana and more and I
brought her to
America and brought three Q To all of them of the college they
finished. As.
So I have a daughter that I call my daughter who's sixty six to Barack of our
daughter this you know my daughter but after her from
combusted West Africa. Her mother is not a WOW WHERE I'M
A Now the woman in
Africa when the white man came to us to pay to go to students here.
They were killed in the blackness so fast to get the Goes to justice a God
they will not go to and is no record nobody made it sound as though they bring
to hell with
it and they were there to take the ghost is a little taken from his chances and see God
critters now and they will kill the men so fast the men got can fly because they're primitive
weapons and so was a little taken while I'm
alive and they hear it in the media and
she's ninety no
one who took her son who was taken a son incidentally America they don't know who it
is and but they could plan but that's
considered last month or is a grand tour now and they put it in a
children's book. They write about why not choose
bachata if she was to do you suppose she was left
open Jr made out of
blue and she said they could see them all it took at
judo so you could observe her and she died in nineteen
or so where mother of African kid. Some
guy to go cause people moment they changed the name but it was a
big
locos so I've been around. Wrong
Paris went to the good news when I was out of the
better. As one than all of
that were issued to come to
your New York as the best people to die.
Went to Paris Paris is a joke joke and put
enough tomato sauce
in were.
That's a chip butty. Pizza but when
you Bill Gates but I mean you know Plymouth to get it in there EVER this
is not
enough and I wonder how little they really have the work to a person die and
they pay yours and me three needs how little
I knew of another nap and I'm going
to a street in November December.
I'm going to Johannesburg where I went to Mandela's first house.
I had to Desmond Tutu. I went to Mandela's
White House. And I went on
safari first and I enjoyed it but we wanted
a group of the Lions could come up to the car park. They have separated by
water and when you see them do good zebras trees to see
if there's a lot of oh they don't want the U.K. see below but I'm going
with so they actually don't bring in potato chips.
Fredo the anything back there because there was no this mother they made up so they
actually don't back the witty lead by the don't bring it because they have you
know big
bucks but they don't tell you please don't buy because they know what it is. And they
found
go to the woman after the year two thousand and
twenty and all that go goes
to Jared. Africa doesn't need it.
They
did platinum I never saw the down the hotel there
Gaiman Africa is a rich. But it's poor because
of the second address and they don't talk about it that's why I don't think any money to
Africa because
it did get rid of the people that are here the ever better have no money
to poor poor because they've been sucked dry because I have to muster what it might so that what they did
in the mines. That's
what can you imagine if they didn't dance and us into
Hell that's the part that they did.
Again list so
legend. Do you
think the
most important change. You see your time your
dues and knew you were for anywhere in Europe
especially. What I was giving the impression
that I
love New York have too many opportunities for
you if you don't get hooked on drugs because the I didn't know how
my hair
was James says Nicky but I
was nowhere in his power and.
I was didn't
want to work at Mt Sinai before I went to work for the city.
I have good union and. I want
to get it in and then I left and went to work for the city because I'm
outside and have a union at the time and
in good doing three giving if it is out we. That would use our
time now to work with the city whose game unit. Won eleven every two years with
a great winning line up so.
If you could just keep our own crowd.
Of people you can make it but if you two would people who down the Dream Team
and and everything else you just can't grasp because when I came
out of nurses school.
We all know all the nurses were two jobs I was working one job.
That I was able to raise my family
out of
how. Go to the pamphlet had bigger
names for the standard
kitchenette and then. For probably going to move
out move a lot of the house into
a neighborhood where she could see that everybody was
heading out of the one hundred
eighty that was my
because I was a grandmother who didn't know her A.B.C..
And ABLE TO SCHOOL I had nobody help me I had to go to the
needs an hour
and I
did and I'm tired of most of about
it and I don't take the stuff up in about an hour
and we're going to do it all kind of Marxism in
because I want people to process what color green
purple just make it with little kids get up and make a living
but something the spirit had when you spirit that you
did and you have
to teach a kid.
On how you got to learn it she taught
me
to law. I see you don't want to learn. She said No I left a
long year later that came back and they were about half an answer
what do you have somebody you know that I was black to you would she say your daughter just graduated out
of school.
I see
what the same over to me that she didn't want to learn it. She only two years
that they got out of college and this of them in the family
will probably not only don't know about a new one Oh you mean
is she still an ongoing process to have that only one of
the cows
again this is she see this
is she to come out the same so when I succeed and I say don't
be asked in the money. If you want them come with me as a
lad and I am so
proud to the injury she took of them
if you have a problem.
And that's not much
it. And
my kids and kids in this illness and some of
the kids. And
they were just as
good and I'm a girl on
a historic asked what was that I don't know she said you will know the
class and he said I didn't know that you knew that
much because I am a blow to chance want to work
because latitude don't know the air is a noun hammer a country to govern to tell people that we're
that we're all in the UK I'm seriously I'm
an alien you are
too. So how did doesn't want to keep you
stupid they can see that
you were
told that we keep Sirius B. is a look this is what we can know the
thing they found it found here is
B. they found a little have the banding but about
it and they alter They came of the sky and with the same in the sky
people in the hopes a blue sky people.
And they will say
to
you and
I wouldn't be
surprised what the how what sounds.
OK now what is the very thing that we have
uncovered.
A lovely fiction movies that we see in Google.
Police found that documents that we do know
is in this country. Once out of
the airport caught a lot of it in went to the
bathroom and he says take the little non-candidate he saying with.
The elevator in the house and they had
a very was so tall. You know better that
tall and this is when issues even tougher method I've been to that airport by the
way I have family
actually
Carrabba's and I went up doing that because I was
not down
from some
of the cars and they sit on the base as opposed
to take a trip back
to lost causes
nothing but walk through
this also into Oakland California Nuno
so they and they have to to I'm not
the one with a
backpack things further out over got to
walk in the park and the
numbers further
out so she stays opponent to motivate the
controller sounds just go. She's awful news. And
she grunted and then
I
looked and saw that come back most
straight. Maybe people. That's
not Rockefeller lost
a song you know they never called you know Peter.
I wonder that
I could hear when you when we when we with the public give
me
more but when I come back to their homes.
Because
anytime. So my life that I've been telling her particularly when I'm you got
me. And that's why I've given them accountable
to catch up and it's you know I don't want to go to the
holding not
of their ideas on making a
success but I always want to meet Castro.
Uber refreezing.